olá a todos pessoal de quem fala é o dar
que seja muito em mim jamais um vídeo e
um estrado de que ex caiping populista
ultimamente o ter estado muito sol sem
flash eu tenho um livro de pipocar ações
mesmo comprei um tabu até há pouco tempo
por isso sempre que eu vou mandar apoia
eu mesma já o flash pois passou horas
dentro da casa de banho e depois da
minha mãe pensa que eu morri abra a
porta de um cheiro a merda que as que
estão entre essa multa que proveria o
méxico estamos aqui com vídeo de frente
por isso espero que vocês gostem
deixando desde logo essas mães que
quiserem ver este ou vídeos e jogos de
classe e tal
dois polícias do mundo não aspirava
surpresa amigo ou mandar uma idéia eu
acho que a não está a perguntar a outros
eo seu ensino aquela caixa é isso aí uma
inspecionou a caixa não foi um polícia
foi da caixa um preso e não sabe o que
tem ali na bahia um bolo com um buraco
ui
meu deus isso é perigoso eu tinha uma
bazuca dentro do bolo um telemóvel a um
trio num treino acho que me é que as
coisas que foram as paredes chão é um
favor é isso o teleporte uma anilha a
não é nerd drinque que não faz mínima
idéia do que quer que seja e uma falha
uma fala que o ficheiro vamos
experimentar o mais óbvio que é o telê
porta e com isso conseguir sair de lá
foi para o acerto com que
ok vamos lá tentar outra coisa porque
pelos vistos não importa não funciona e
eu acabei de cruzar o mapa eu sei que
vocês viram mas não interessa ataque
vamos lá por imitar o tufo não muito
forte não porque ou se conseguem ver o
cliente e sabem culto ligar pra fora da
prisão por isso não o telefone não eu
acho que nos calar instrumento já a
porta eu sair daqui e você não olha ela
vai interpretar ela imprime nessa série
meu qual é produzir lado isto acontecer
uma bala visto tamanho de uma prazo cana
entrou na minha cabeça por um cano
vamos tentar dentro de um golo teve como
furar o chão eu do rock ou não estou
vivo
agora temos um mapa se sair tanto não
faz idéia do que é que isto já o bar que
é um pé de cabra ok vamos comentar ou
aceitar eu sei que está na bosta mas
como eu não sei o que é que eu vou usar
roupas ea não é uma piscina e também mal
eo ala cruzou ou sair eu consigo andar
pelo sprint com isto é isso
o título do google sai a pena que eu
consiga andar pelas paredes bolton
fantasma agora isso vai ocorrer uma aula
luiz rosa outra coisa não faz sentido eu
caí no meio da terra dentro do solo
lunar que não existem só de dentro da
terra tá bom vou tentar agora um pé de
cabra
a única função está mais ou menos né ok
isso entrar dentro do tubo e quem não
vai dois clubes por onde você precisa
mostrar uma capa o alvo o eu sou deus
acabou a espera
ah tá bom
fui atingido por uma bala meu deus tomou
a não procurar outra vez mais lá eu vou
sentir pronto aqui e acesse
não é possível dois times daqui a pouco
para conseguir mais anda não estou a
acompanhar o filho da mãe rocha e vamos
fugir daqui jogador nada que indique que
se fosse enfrenta o irã contra a parede
não faz sentido agora vai agora vai
anda não eu disse um colega de chapa foi
rápido
eu falei aqui
oi oi olha pra mim que eu sou o atrix o
patrão polícia na porta voz
fred vai acontecer alguma coisa tentar
pronto
não sei o que vai acontecer mas está
pronto para levar seu currículo uma foto
igual a sério é não
embora o aborto agora através do espaço
de tempo por uma música do texas
além deste jogo a rápido rápido
vamos agora não escutar brutal perguntou
o bicho
quando espero que vocês ok
esta foi o que mais subiu de sempre
gostei porque fugir da prisão o que foi
isso não percebi que eu não percebi que
fui e voltei um pouco esse modelo já que
o café
ok pessoal eu vou tentar agora é usar
outros objetos para conseguir fugir eu
não sei se aquela era a única fuga ou
não mas eu vou tentar outros
eu tenho experimentado a brazucah o
teleporte e o drillo consegui fugir
kudrin eu vou tentar com energy drink
long é de henares também toma para
sempre o que aconteceu neste uma vai
além na cabeça
oh meu deus tem super força
o músico é esta não é o primeiro com uma
faca isso é permitido eu agarrei no
polícia é meu estilo um ok a equipe tudo
isso a comer frango conseguir sentir mal
o último rei com o ataque do united
josé ao cair não funcionou muito bem e
vamos tentar o que o telefone lá família
e amigos para eu ficar em juízo
o bloco tem que fazer aqui não sai eu
tenho que fazer é não sair o gol jogo
choveu na máquina não sabe o que a gente
consegue com o paulo o juiz preso após
brincarem vai enfocar o último trio a
música de mateus mestre not guilty não
culpado consegui então qualquer sujeira
só que agora trocou a turma da linha da
pobreza
não vou ficar à espera não só para sair
já conseguiu fugir
eu acho que já só me faltava usaram lima
por isso eu vou tentar usar a lima e ver
o que vai acontecer porque eu fiquei
curioso porque a única coisa que nós
vamos lá vamos nós podemos usar isso né
na porta ou janela vamos painel já eu
acho que não vai ter muito cuidado
foi já calculava isso não era fogo ferro
mais grosso isso não é muito bem pensado
o gol
inclusive uma semana a gente casar eu
lhe peço desculpa toma chupa ano ocupam
um choque porque houve choques time até
agora vai agora vai ocupar o lugar meu
ato foi também graças foi mais dizem mas
mais dois
eu conheço o meu pau ferro ou cair nesta
sala a esta sala no rock um cinto de
gramados e nos primeiros cinco granadas
e uma câmera canon ok uma boa câmera foi
mais duro entrarmos com tudo bem que
lançar um novo spot das curvas desta vez
de ser a única hipótese e vuk sakineh
não pode lá pra baixo panela wok bush
uma ganhou uma corda é termos um
desentupidor temos um paraquedas de um
gp que buscam um paraquedas porque é o
mais lógico né
agora para quem digitação ou então não
aguentam paraquedas falha e tudo ficar
lá embaixo
isso já está previsível supostamente o
que é mais lógico é o que não é para
usar então o programa usado
desentupidora ok é sério não não a série
do sério
não sinto dor nenhum dos entupido dor e
cola na pedra
isso não existe